like where do you start first thing is
you start learning I nowadays love
reading biographies of people of
successful I mean not just entrepreneurs
but really all kinds of people you hear
their story and their Journeys it's not
just motivational but very educational
indirectly because you get to hear what
they did from their own opinions so it's
like you know what would you pay to have
lunch with Warren Buffett well it
doesn't matter what you pay it's not
worth his time so now you start learning
the second thing you start doing and so
if you have a job do it in addition to
that don't just quit your job unless you
have the financial resources to fall
back on it's going to be hard because
you're going to say well I'm already
working so much and I got kids and I
know it's hard when there's a will
there's a way and this is so true with
every aspect of Our Lives if you really
want to make a change you will find a
way to do it you'll wake up an hour
earlier you'll go to bed an hour later
you will find some time on the weekends
you'll find sometimes in the middle of
your work day to do something just
remember it gives you energy your
purpose gives you energy